il n'y a désormais plus aucun doute le
chef de l'opposition afghane le
commandant massoud n'a pas survécu à
l'attentât suicide dont il a été victime
dimanche dernier soit deux jours avant
les attentats de new york et de
washington
il était dans son pays le dernier
rempart au régime intégriste des
talibans ceux qui jouent à 48 ans
l'indomptable l'infatigable chef de la
résistance afghane est finalement tombé
victime d'un attentat à l'explosif
perpétré par ces deux kamikazes qui
s'étaient présentés comme des
journalistes arabes stratège hors pair
le commandant massoud avait durant dix
ans tenu tête à l'armée soviétique
depuis quelques années après un bref
passage au pouvoir il avait repris la
lui cette fois contre les talibans ces
fondamentalistes de kaboul qui héberge
oussama ben laden interrogé cet été au
sujet de la menace talibane
le commandant massoud avait été sans
ambiguïté les terroristes réside en
afghanistan mais leur action et leur
influence peuvent toucher le monde
entier lui qui disait être le dernier
rempart contre le terrorisme aura été
reçu avec tous les honneurs au parlement
de strasbourg et à paris en avril
dernier
reçus mais pas très écouté nous avons
trouvé un homme de paix un homme
extraordinaire très courageux mais qui
étaient venus nous demander de l'aider à
faire la paix en afghanistan
je pense pouvoir dire que cet appel a
vraiment été très entendu du parlement
européen je regrette qu'il ne l'est pas
et c'était mieux de la part des
gouvernements occidentaux
les proches de massoud ont exprimé leur
détresse cet après midi à paris ils
savent qu'avec la disparition du chef de
la résistance afghane
les maîtres de kaboul ont désormais les
mains libres à l'intérieur du pays